we have a lot to catch up on by the way
thank you for the comments in the last
video that we did some of you guys were
dicks we had to ban a few people but all
in all we did appreciate the
constructive criticism right tony was
really awesome for picking up the slack
a mental health break was absolutely
needed but one of you guys said you
could definitely see this channel being
like a g4 type channel where you've got
like a different cast for different
types of shows that's kind of what we're
shooting for so i'm glad that some of
you guys are picking up on that idea but
we've got some stuff
to talk about right
world war hulk
yeah
yeah i'm down with world war hulk
it's crazy i tell the world i'm going to
take a mental health break for a week
and the marvel studios is like dump it
all out there right it's it's it was
probably a bad time to take a mental
health break the batman trailer came out
right haven't seen it yet i have not
watched it i wanted to to watch it
before i made a video on it here right
let's talk about world war hawk right
that's that's what we're here to talk
about let's talk about world war hulk
world war hulk was legit it's probably
one of the best incredible hulk stories
ever written right if you're like one of
the hipster fans it's future imperfect
but world war hulk is just one of the
absolute best incredible hulk stories
ever written right so here's the thing
behind here's the three minutes we
covered the whole thing like comments
explaining right literally the entire
run of greg pack including heart of the
monster hulk which is the most powerful
version of the hulk we've ever seen
literally this guy was smashing the
dimension of dormammu right like
literally mamamoo's sister umar who runs
the dimension at the time she goes and
finds doctor strange like you got to do
something about this guy man because
he's literally fracturing the
dimensional barrier it's like if you
punch the universe and you were starting
to break it that's basically what was
happening right hulk was just that
strong it was nuts it was absolutely
amazing right so here's the thing here's
the thing so so suppose the movie is
going to start filming next year right
they're going to get the whole thing
going and everything's going to happen
next year the news came out a couple
days ago as part of a big leak and a
period of this leak was confirmed and so
if we get this if they do it anything
close to what we saw in the comics you
guys are not prepared right so check
this out check this out here's what
happens in this thing so it all kind of
goes back to the illuminati right and it
kind of makes sense because supposedly
we're going to see him in doctor strange
too which would be really really cool if
we did the rumors are saying that
spider-man three and doctor strange two
are just gonna totally rework everything
and if that's true it's gonna be amazing
i'm super excited for that but the thing
about this is that this this super
clandestine group serve the purpose of
protecting the earth from like various
threats they end up looking at the
incredible hulk from his most recent
tirade in vegas at the time and they say
okay all this guy does is just rip stuff
up the earth is better off without the
hulk so like dicks they trick the hulk
onto a ship right because they're like
you're the only one who can save the
people on the ship hulk you got to go
and save them so hulk's like okay cool
he gets there there's no astronauts or
nothing and there's like this
pre-recorded message where they're like
sorry hulk uh all you do is rampage so
like you gotta go so they basically like
send them flying into space he's mad as
hell right they sent him flying into
space he was supposed to go to a
peaceful world where he could live out
the rest of his life uh in just like
harmony right like there was literally
no life on this world no sentient life
right i mean i guess there were like
animals and stuff you know but like he
was gonna live his life like a disney
character you know he holds out his hand
and like birds land in it right yeah i
mean you know what i'm talking about
like that kind of a thing right that was
supposed to be the hulk's life and
instead he ends up flying through a
gravity well and he lands on a planet
called sakhar now you guys know sakhar
from thor 3. thor 3 in a lot of ways the
first part of the movie is basically
planet hulk with thor attached to it so
basically imagine everything you saw in
the first part of thor 3 except instead
of thor it was the incredible hulk and
instead of like thor fighting hulk it
was hulk fighting the silver surfer
that's basically what happened it was
amazing the fight between silver surfer
and hulk was lit dude i loved that fight
so much dude he beat the hell out of the
silver surfer it was nuts but what ends
up happening right so nick's the entire
second half of thor right after like the
tournament and all that kind of stuff
the great big huge battle so nix all of
that right and start introducing these
ideas that like there's basically what's
called the old strong so essentially
people who can like manipulate the
ground right manipulate like tectonic
plates and stuff like that and so hulk
ends up getting with this girl named
kaira who's a member of the old strong
they cast off the ruler of the world
named the red king and then in turn like
the day is saved the incredible hulk's
referred to as the sikarson he's like
the new leader of the world and all that
kind of cool stuff turns out the ship
that hulk was sent to that planet on has
a nuclear reactor it detonates it kills
chiara who's actually pregnant with the
incredible hulk's unborn son and the
incredible hulk loses it right just
absolutely freaks so he comes back to
earth
mad as hell right grabs his entire
entourage right this dude this dude just
you guys remember that snl skit where
like obama's just like bam kixa in it's
that right like he shows up he is pissed
so the first person he comes across is
black bolt of the inhumans which is not
impressive because black bolt sucks
right like he literally is like i want
to hear you scream right and like that
kind of thing and this starts going
after each one of the members of the
illuminati the coolest thing about this
is when he confronts the x-men dude it
was amazing i absolutely love that so
much check this out it's the craziest
thing ever crazy is the craziest
craziest thing
i'm sorry i'm so excited people but it
is an exciting story man it's it's
man let me tell you something okay so
here's the here's the thing here's the
thing right so he shows up at the
x-men's house i feel like i should just
take the whole thing of the run down
from comics explain and just do it here
because this is basically an episode of
the rundown i feel like i should just do
that here right like here's the quick
and dirty strip down version of what we
do with comics explained right like i
think that'd be amazing so he shows up
at the xavier institute right you have
like colossus right you guys know
colossus right you know osmium metal
skin he grows like twice the size he's
huge right so like like colossus shows
up and he was like hulk you need to
leave and hulk's like whatever man i'm
here to see xavier bring xavier out
right now i don't mean now i mean right
now right like bring him out right now
and so like colossus is like no that's
not gonna happen and so colossus and
basically world breaker hulk at this
point get into a fight dude that fight
was five seconds long it was
he
was not prepared dude colossus gets his
arms snapped right he breaks his arms in
his metal form he's just like bam right
like kane marco the juggernaut shows up
and like comes running at world breaker
hook and he's like nope and just like
uses his momentum and just sends him
like flying in the other direction and
so finally xavier comes out you end up
realizing the scarlet witch took away
like 98 of the mutant population and so
hope's like okay you suffered enough but
he ends up like facing it like forcing
all the illuminati to face each other
right enter the century dude robert
reynolds man dude this guy the whole
time the century's just sitting there
just watching it all unfold he's kind of
like yeah man the illuminati kind of had
it coming those guys are sort of dicks
right like i know what it's like to be
like cast off by the superhero community
to be ignored and disrespected or
whatever but eventually he's like i
can't stand idly by and watch this
happen so like him and the hulk get into
a fight right this is world breaker hulk
this guy is so strong he stomps on the
ground and shakes the east coast it's
crazy like imagine if you saw that in
infinity war avengers thinking oh my god
imagine if you saw that infinity war
winter's end game right like imagine if
something like that happened right like
banner snaps his fingers half the life
comes back and then he asks about like
betty ross and they're like no betty
ross was killed in the attack by thanos
she was not killed when he blinked out
half the life of the universe and he
freaks right so you got like this great
big huge battle going on it's just just
huge conflict you know like the battle
at the end of the movie you hear all the
stuff banner like gets that news right
when this battle is going on like the
middle of it all and then you hear like
this roar that sounds like it would echo
across the world and like the ground
shakes like and i mean like it shakes
multiple times like the hulk is walking
to the battlefield and the ground shakes
and like thanos goes to attack him and
he's just like one shot and like
that's it right that would be oh my god
that would be so amazing world breaker
hulk during infinity war would have been
crazy amazing but nonetheless okay so so
back on track back on track right so
basically what ends up happening is like
century in the incredible hope fight to
a standstill during that time iron man
ends up firing off these satellites that
forces banner to revert into his current
form and then he's basically locked in a
prison in new mexico three miles below
ground and then jeff loeb writes a story
about the red hulk but it was cool man
here's the crazy thing about this as
powerful as like world war hulk is he's
got nothing on heart of the monster hulk
dude this guy was so powerful he was
fracturing the dimension of dormammu
it's like you getting so mad that like
you just punch space and fracture the
universe right i mean it was like that
right this guy was breaking an entire
dimension of one of the most powerful
beings to ever exist in the history of
marvel comics technically it was ruled
by a sister umar at the time but still
right it's just it's it's crazy what was
going on here that story would be
phenomenal in the mcu the real question
is how do you take a story like that and
put it into the marvel cinematic
universe in a way that works and
honestly i don't really know that
question the only way to do it is like
the death of betty ross because it ended
up being the death of of the incredible
hulk's wife kiera what he perceived to
be at the hands of the illuminati that
set all that motion right but like the
one chance banner had for a life of
happiness was now completely and totally
gone i don't know what that catalyst
would be you could have made an argument
that it would have been the death of
black widow but like that time's come
and gone there's no there's no like you
know well banner just now learned that
black widow died okay well like what was
he doing during like the entire final
battle of endgame because like you kind
of knew she was dead was he like well i
mean you know she's probably off doing
some spy stuff like he knew she was dead
so like at that point the idea that like
he could he could hulk out that time has
come and gone right betty ross could
potentially die but what's the catalyst
for betty ross stein because it can't be
some kind of throwaway thing or unless
they build it on the idea that betty
ross is so significant to the incredible
hulk that no matter how she dies that he
freaks out and loses his mind i don't
really know how that's gonna work i
think it would be cool i think it'd be
awesome i think a great callback if they
really really really want to tie this in
and make it awesome a great callback
would be to say this is what banner saw
during the events of avengers age of
ultron because i've said it before we
never found out what banners saw right
when the scarlet witch was messing with
their heads we saw steve rogers who kind
of had like you know a chance to
actually dance with peggy carter we saw
that like black widow was reliving her
time in the red room everybody had their
own individual visions and it was cool
to see that unfold but you never saw
what happened with dana i mean thor got
his vision but it was really more of a
catalyst to him looking up the infinity
stones because idris elba was like you
killed us bro
good going thor like it was like it was
a catalyst right to the events that led
into infinity war and avengers in-game
but we never got to see what hulk saw i
personally would have preferred to have
seen him become maestro but i still
think it would be cool if we if the
events he saw was actually the events of
world war hulk that would be great that
would be absolutely awesome because what
it could indicate is that like banner
loses control of the hulk persona right
that that by and large since we've seen
the incredible hulk in the mcu it's
largely been banner having some measure
of restraint in this situation
especially when you go into the events
of like infinity war when like he gets
absolutely thrashed by thanos and the
hulk won't come out so he has to use
iron man's uh hulkbuster armor instead
that like there's always kind of a
situation that goes on there and even
now during the events are really the the
post-endgame landscape when you've got
what's basically professor hulk right so
the incredible hulk and bruce banner
working in unison that something happens
and banner loses control of the whole
persona and the hulk gets his gets more
mad than he's ever been and just loses
it right i mean that'd be a great way to
bring the character in but at the end of
the day i'm still curious what would the
catalyst be so i'm going to ask you guys
that question right if something's going
to cause world war hulk to happen what's
that cost what's the thing that drives
banner or drives the incredible hulk to
totally take over banner to lose
complete and total control or to
possibly even give up control and gives
us the events of world war hulk with
that being said guys it's exciting it's
an exciting piece of news i'm hyped for
it but thank you guys for watching good
to be back and i will catch you all
later
peace